[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sei de um lugar para onde todo mundo
está indo todo mundo tem gente que está
indo na marra
cabisbaixo tem gente que está indo
sorrindo seduzido
tem gente que é curioso tem gente que
pesquisa esse lugar se chama futuro mas
é um título ao futuro
eu quero fazer uma brincadeira aqui com
vocês eu vou pedir pra vocês contarem
comigo até três quando chegar número 3
a gente vai pegar esse dedo aqui e
apontar na direção para onde vocês acham
que está o futuro tá bom vamos lá todo
mundo o 23 vão lá
bom acho que a maioria voltou pra frente
alguns apontaram para cima né
parece óbvio né a gente apontar pra
frente mas existem é culturas que acham
que o futuro está aqui atrás porque o
futuro não é visível ele é misterioso
ele é desconhecido
e aqui na frente a gente tem o passado
que a gente conhece que a gente visita e
revisita ea gente conhece pessoas e
empresas que quando elas olham para a
frente elas venham passado e elas
caminham e tomam decisões olhando para o
passado
quem nunca né mas a idéia de futuro
gente tem a ver com a nossa cultura e
com a língua que a gente fala existem
culturas asiáticas em que o tempo é
visto verticalmente futuro e passado
existem muitos futuros o futuro é plural
o futuro ele pode ser muito caótico ou
abundante mas ele não será abundante
assim num passe de mágica
nós cidadãos globais
temos que ter vontade de ter um futuro
abundante para todos contra as pandemias
contra o aquecimento global contra as
armas de destruição em massa a asfic
news o colapso da internet e contra a
inteligência artificial na mão de poucos
esse dia de hoje que você está vivendo é
um futuro que você projetou o futuro que
atropelou intencionalidade intenção
essa palavra começou a rondar a minha
cabeça e eu fui ao dicionário e vi que
existe intenção com esse dia como a
gente podia imaginar e intenção com essa
intenção concedida a gente quer dizer
vontade intenção com s
quer dizer intensidade força mais uma
palavrinha para gente mais uma
palavrinha a gente tem que ter a
intenção para poder se poderá pra poder
engajar pessoas colaboraram para poder
compartilhar conhecimento para poder
renovar para poder acolher a diversidade
esse futuro que a gente é tá buscando
ele tem uma única novidade a velocidade
das mudanças que nós estamos vivendo é
exponencialmente e exponencial é uma
dessas palavrinhas que é muito difícil
de entrar na nossa rotina porque a gente
está aqui na vida do dia a dia a gente
está na batalha de correr atrás do mês
mas nós precisamos entender que as
mudanças lineares vagarosas degrau por
degrau
ficaram atrás no século 20
junto com aquelas habilidades que não
tem mais valor
agora que nós estamos entrando na
terceira década do século 21
para fazer parte do futuro nós vamos ter
que ter muita vontade e muita garra e
também nos deixar que o futuro não se
reduza
mas o que tem lá no futuro no futuro tem
as perguntas que a gente tem que fazer
sobre o presente quanto mais a gente
caminha da grama do futuro
mas a gente é invadido por uma vontade
de construir e eu tenho um exemplo pra
vocês que aconteceu comigo em 2015 eu
fiquei enlouquecida com a possibilidade
de participar de uma conferência em
londres chamada antecipando 2040
era tudo que o futurista podia querer
ficar entre os bambas do futuro em
londres é uma cidade que eu adoro mas
gente 2015 é o começo da crise nem
pensar em gastar dinheiro com viagens
mas eu vi aquela conferência naquele
futuro em meio a vários futuros
e eu falei isso é muito importante pra
mim muito importante para o meu negócio
e muito importante para o meu futuro de
palestrante futurista e aí eu resolvi
fazer um crowd funding como os
brasileiros dizem uma vaquinha virtual
a vaquinha era para as empresas quem
contribuísse ganhar ia palestra sobre
mas em 2015 gente as empresas estavam
mais preocupadas com o fim do dia do que
com o fim da década
elas não se envolveram
mas os amigos começaram a contribuir e
15 dias antes do evento eu tinha a
metade do dinheiro da viagem só metade e
aí meus filhos falar vai faz das tripas
coração mas vai e eu tremendo de medo
comprei as passagens
nesse mesmo dia um diretor de marketing
de uma grande empresa entrou no
messenger e me disse eu adoro esse
detalhe do messenger é verdade
aí ele me disse béia estou em paris
chego no brasil em dois dias
vou fechar a sua quota mas nem pensar
que eu vou explicar o que é cloud
funding primeiro financeiro tá
e foi assim gente com uma empresa
vivendo no passado e um diretor de
marketing vivendo no futuro que eu fui
pra 2040 meu futuro se realizou no
presente nem sempre que dá certo tá mas
se você não tentar também não dá certo
vamos lá tem um nome pra isso gente
design design é desenvolver um projeto é
trabalhar uma intenção é trabalhar com
cenários futuros que possam vir a
acontecer
eu trabalhei no cenário futuro a
conferência
eu trabalhei a minha intenção eu
desenvolvi um projeto crowdfunding
eu olhei as possibilidades as
perspectivas e não as metas e as
métricas
eu não tenho tempo para o futuro
essa frase é a desculpa que leva pessoas
empresas a serem atropeladas todos os
dias pelo futuro
ninguém vai pegar sua mãozinha e vai te
levar lá no futuro isso é uma coisa que
você vai ter que fazer sozinho com uma
intensa intenção
nós estamos exatamente no momento do
século 21 que nós temos todos os motivos
para acreditar que tudo pode mudar e
temos todas as provas para acreditar que
todas as loucuras que tinham que
acontecer
já aconteceram eu que os gringos chamam
de the tipping point é esse ponto aonde
tudo aquilo que se ouve o que acontecer
lá no futuro muito longínquo vai passar
sobre você
de uma forma muito intensa e aquele
presente tão quentinha familiar cheio de
velhas certezas será reconfigurado eu
aprendi três coisas da conferência de
2040 que a gente tem que pensar as novas
relações
a gente tem que construir redes de
trabalho e ouvir as crianças uma nova
era gente pede que a gente desenhe as
nossas relações com as novas tecnologias
e as novas tecnologias de aceleração
elas nos aceleram elas nos catapultam as
novas tecnologias nós precisamos saber
se a gente que tipo de relação a gente
quer com as novas tecnologias por
exemplo a inteligência artificial
a gente quer ser amigo da inteligência
artificial ou nós seremos subjugados por
ela
afinal nós somos ou não somos os animais
mais inteligentes da face da terra tem
um futurista chamado carvalho que disse
que a inteligência artificial é humana
porque fomos nós que inventamos no
futuro não vai ter muito emprego mas vai
ter muito trabalho e vai ter trabalho
para quem se aliar às tecnologias de
aceleração porque as tecnologias de
aceleração nos aceleram nos catapultam
para o futuro não fujam delas é com elas
que nós vamos criar as redes de trabalho
deste século é com elas e com indivíduos
bombados por tecnologia que nós vamos
resolver problemas de saúde de educação
de encarceramento de corrupção
distribuição de alimentos de redes de
esgoto e também tentar resolver
problemas de sermos seres humanos
melhores
se você está já começando a sua jornada
para o futuro
converse com as crianças não ensine
pergunte não de ordens aprenda as
crianças nos dão várias pistas do que a
gente deve aprender para ter um do
abundante em 2050
nós seremos 10 bilhões de pessoas 3
bilhões a mais do que hoje não vai dar
pra todo mundo ter coisas em abundância
no futuro será melhor ser do que ter se
joguem para o futuro mas se joguem com
uma intensa intenção e contem com a
gente
os futuristas tem todo o tempo para o
futuro
obrigada e boa viagem
regata
[Aplausos]